[Applause]
donald say he wants to run for uh
president and move on into the white
house why not
it wouldn't be the first time you pushed
the black family out of their home
look the g-line will fly
how did i get this show i don't know
whoa
baby
hey hey wait a minute wait a minute hey
no
no
after the jimmy fallon fly the very rare
craig ferguson big fan
oh
wow any more flies there was the
nicholas cage fly oh okay i'ma fly here
i am oh oh i'm flying
oh yeah
[Laughter]
any more arnold schwarzenegger arnold
schwarzenegger
wow
[Applause]
what about
what about morgan freeman fly yeah the
morgan freeman fly narrates his own
flight pattern okay
here i am flying through the air
strong wings translucent
i'm going to go find some duty to sit on
because i'm a fly
thank you i i tell you what a really
cool line which i wish they'd let be in
the movie i need to watch this movie you
haven't seen spider-man
[Laughter]
i haven't seen the falcon oh no there
isn't one sorry
things that are you're supposed to be
afraid of there's a reason that you're
afraid of an anaconda you don't want to
get near it i wouldn't go well then
you're a little [ __ ] that's not my
father
[Applause]
conan saying my wife loves the horse
and she's going to keep the horse
because she's an equestrian
i'm presbyterian are you jewish no
you're a bully
with a capital b
you come here and you bully people with
words that we don't understand half that
stuff ain't even in a dictionary excuse
me that would be him you got the that
would be him that would be him that's
not me i've got nothing on him you're
looking at a player that's colossus
what did you say that would be good
he colosticizes in and that makes him a
traumatic disaster occasion what
and the golden globe goes too
you want to open it you want me to do it
yeah i have the nails yeah get after it
you got the globes too um
billy bob forden fargo
[Applause]
wow
that is fantastic
this is the sound of a snake going up
emily's ass
no come on
sam mendes mum scorsese todd phillips
quinton tarantino
i don't think i could do what they do
honestly
i just don't have the balls
congratulations on your new stupid thank
you very much indeed it's a little
smaller than yours i couldn't even
actually tell the difference from the
last not really no you can
you can't but yours is huge it's like
it's nice it's a lot more expensive
right yeah yeah well that's what you
want though you're an expensive girl i
look at you and i think
that's money right there
is it different working in it do you
feel like it is it feels very exciting i
feel like i'm a big girl like i feel
like i went from high school to college
you know what i mean oh yeah yeah you
know about that oh i know about big
girls yeah yeah
how do you feel when you see me do you
get like a direction yeah yeah sure yeah
well um no not all the time you know
well you are older that's my age yeah
it's not gonna happen every time like no
but if it happens at all i'm like hello
[Music]
the uh celtics 36 36 why 36. that's how
many points you had like in a month
[Laughter]
all right cavaliers
33
why 33
that's how many points you had in two
months
if i had four reasons
oh man now when jeff was born his mother
[ __ ] during the delivery
and when she looked down she thought she
had twins
that's why he's so corny
as of next week
we're going to be
rivals
yeah well i don't ever think of us like
no no no because i'm on a saturday night
you're on a friday night you're on the
night when they put the gay talk shows
and i've been straight zoned
like an english or an irish i like
irishman you like irish guys not your
type but like this
did you talk to him yet no i don't talk
to dummies
god bless
yeah you be careful with him he's he's
spiteful he doesn't have that
guy you don't want to dress up like that
you need the job i mean
god bless you know you're very good in
this are you really you really are sir
you're a legend i loved you in toy story
oh i'm
no you're right you were being nice he
was being taken i can have him unplugged
[Music]
all of his movies well yeah i loved all
of his movies that's the thing i mean
home alone and no yeah i love that one
those are beverly hills cops
what are you talking about that's not my
movie oh you know what no no no no
okay what's great this is that's chris
roth and you just name another black
community you're not even
you're not even trying i consider amy
schumer the funniest person on the
planet
if you take me out of the equation
no i meant me
that's why
i was clearing my throat yeah
not you i thought you were clearing your
throat for me no no
no taking you out of the aquarium
who's most likely to survive a real-life
jungle cruise adventure that would be
new because you have more fat on you
so you'd last longer
look at everybody's head popped up i
would be uh the raccoon
raccoon
yeah i'm going for group yeah i got a
second one okay i would be spiderman
because i can make that movie much
better than that
you know how sometimes when people get
under your skin and you just hate them
i'm not what are you saying it's you i'm
just saying there's some times where you
just really hate somebody sometimes you
have that personality when you walk in
and you're like you think everyone's
like hey there's kevin great but you
probably know me as the creator of the
office
no you don't do you you think steve
corral did it all oh
he's brilliant isn't he steve corral
he's amazing as the bumbling office
manager
where does he get his ideas from
let's play it
he doesn't do it to me
he doesn't do it he has nothing to say
let me finish you know and then he
starts going in his soliloquy and it
doesn't matter what he said
he was not you didn't have to say
solidify right there it didn't fit but
why didn't you use it because that's how
i told him
he wakes up and there's somebody that
gives them seven words he has to use in
that day actually i give myself
something soliloquy was a word that he
had to use today i read the dictionary
every day i'm so sick of you man
you dude let me tell you something you
don't you don't
minimize nothing
hi chris pratt i have i have a question
for mr chris pratt yes tom go right
ahead so so my question for you is um of
all the actors in the world of all of
the actors who
who is who is your favorite actor
these are people he worked with you're
talking about just anyone okay oh this
is all of them all the actors in the
world go ahead denzel
denzel washington yeah yeah he's great
no don't apologize
i'm sorry okay that's cool i like denzel
too um
okay how do i okay what about how about
an actor whose name begins with tom
oh how about that tom cruise
he's great he's good he's top gun he's
coming out he's good he's got okay i
could simplify it for you again
what if his second name began with an h
tom h oh
hanks
beautiful day in the neighborhood yeah
that was good too it was good yeah real
good he's british
all right thomas british no
he's damaged british come on we know who
oh he oh i see where this is going okay
we've got him now tom hardy
he played venom yeah he was very he was
great warrior great movie yeah okay can
that answer your question
try younger
but still with the
still with the tom h you still with the
tom h thanks oh wow
hiddleston oh yeah
is shiri lewis going to be here yeah
yeah
[Applause]